well let's talk about this we got a
story from the independent
put people in jail former fox reporter
calls for arrests over right wing's
great replacement theory tucker carlson
responded saying this is going to get
really ugly really soon
slamming x fox news colleague who
suggested he should be in jail or
something worse
what's something worse carlson asked his
audience after hearing a clip of the
remarks from the former reporter cameron
made uh over the weekend at cnn we're
not sure what something worse is but it
certainly feels like we're moving toward
it at a very high speed at this point
rhetoric has its own internal logic
we've experienced it we can talk
ourselves into things democrats are
doing it right now and what they're
talking themselves into right now is
quote something worse it's scary it's
time to pull back it's time to
de-escalate otherwise this is going to
get really ugly really soon
so um you know should i say the magic
word civil war
you can always say it i mean i would i
would hope that everybody ignores um
people like that on the extreme they
don't right
i mean some people do some people don't
right like you know i have my friends
from silicon valley are all democrats
but they're not going to say carlos
should be executed for talking about
replacement theory
but are they are they active in politics
are they the the public speakers
no exactly so you have on cnn here's
what happens i i don't think intent
matters on either side as this conflict
escalates this guy goes on cnn they
probably didn't know he was going to say
this he says it they probably say okay
well that's a little over the top but
you know we know we don't mean it right
we don't we don't want to go that far
but then tucker carlson sees it and then
he talks about it and says look what
they're doing look what they're saying
and then of course people who see that
are like whoa those people are crazy so
it's it's it's exacerbating the problem
it's escalating things regardless of
whether they're being tongue-in-cheek or
hyperbolic or otherwise
feels like the network should be
responsible for these people that are
talking on the network i know it's not a
social network so they don't have
i don't know 230
imperative but they don't they don't
they don't care though because they know
they don't make money from trump
supporters they have no cultural tie to
conservatives republicans or
libertarians but this guy's saying
something worse the only thing worse
than jail for a criminal's death penalty
that i'd know of mean you either life in
prison or death penalty that's the next
thing that's worse uh so what's this guy
going cnn and suggesting that someone
needs the death penalty for talking on a
news channel and now people are going to
hear you needs to come out and say speak
against that and so whether whether uh
anyone has the the full intent of it or
not people will hear us talking about it
right and they're going to be like man
these cnn people have lost their minds
allowing this yeah they're gonna say
ian's right they shouldn't allow that
this guy's calling for the death penalty
for tucker carlson that's crazy and then
you'll mention my democrat friends don't
believe that but this is something at
the highest level of the conversation
right right i would say that
you know it's kind of all of our
collective responsibility to do what you
can i mean i do what i can to keep my
democrat friends a lot of them you know
i'm an independent and i've still lost a
lot of
friends you know just by being a little
bit more outspoken
but try to make an effort to stay
friends with people there most people
are reasonable like and you know if you
point out things like this to them
they'll probably be yeah that's batshit
crazy i didn't i thought all the bat
[ __ ] crazy people were on the right i
didn't realize there were bat [ __ ] crazy
people on my side too
yeah uh it was part in the french oh
i'll do that i'll do a little bit uh
try and do a little a little bit of that
reconciliation say like look what he
said is is totally legal i mean what
he's suggesting is ridiculous and
unconstitutional and a million other
things but you know him saying that that
should be the penalty for saying things
he doesn't you know believe or
should be said on on public error i mean
i guess you can say that how does he get
to that point how does this guy get to
the point where we'd actually say
something worse than jailing for talking
about an idea pushed by so i just want
to clarify that he should lose his job i
don't know he said he said go to jail or
something like a jail for a week or lose
your job i don't know i wouldn't
apologize for it i'm not what i would
what i would say is these people
i'm sorry i i don't know how we solve
this because i think they're nuts and
i'll tell you why
it has been many prominent democrats who
have argued for demographic change in an
effort to maintain power
when tucker carlson points that out they
accuse him of pushing a conspiracy
theory and i'll say it again many
democrats have said
immigration is a path towards
maintaining political power
tucker carlson says look what they're
saying he shows them saying it and they
say he has said something so dangerous
he should be jailed or something worse
how do they get to that point
look i know donald trump said locker up
to hillary clinton
right maybe that's it maybe maybe it's
inevitable hillary clinton actually did
bad things
joe biden did bad things
yeah but political persecution is not
the answer that's free so what do you do
then do you say hillary clinton
destroyed 30 000 emails but we're not
going to go after her because it would
he should he should say she should be
charged not locked up that's the judge
to decide or the jury
and then everyone says criminally charge
my opponent you criminally charge yours
everyone says they're right you know you
mentioned it on the show before the left
says the exact same thing about us that
we say about them and then i pointed out
yeah but we're right
like we when i say joe biden
went to the pro went to the president of
ukraine and said if you don't fire the
prosecutor you're not getting the
billion dollar loan guarantees that's on
video he actually did that a prosecutor
who was investigating barisma where his
son was on the board all of that
happened
well that should be investigated but
then they push things like the ahmed
arbory lie the guy who filmed it goes to
prison you know trayvon martin george
floyd i mean all of these things that
were embellished hands up don't shoot
outright not true justice millet they
all believed it they keep pushing all
these things that are just outright
falsehoods
but you have it's it's almost like man
an equal and opposite reaction as more
people get access to the truth through
social media more people join the
zealous cult as a as an equal and
opposite reaction is that really it is
there is there is the is the is that law
of thermodynamics just a reality for
every element of existence we have free
will it exists within our energy but we
have free will like when something i
think that people are doing too much
these days too fast with politics like
you don't need to make a change like
today we're like what's going on with
the news there's not a lot of news today
good let's live in peace that's the idea
and and these these feelings like they
gotta legislate and create new law new
law new lawn sign this and that like
dude what
maybe it's like that um
that episode of star trek
where bellat which one is that is the
half white half black no no no
where they're uh
they have this this energy pulse
slamming into the enterprise and so
they're like raise the shields and then
they're like the energy pulse is getting
stronger and they keep doing it and then
finally i think it's uh was it data or
somebody says lower the shields and
they're like are you sure do it and they
do and then the energy wave dissipates
and it was that the more they increased
their shields the more the refl the
energy reflected back stronger
like a like a chinese finger trap you've
got to stop pulling as hard as you can
and just push in then you can get your
fingers out become friends with your
enemy and all of a sudden there's no
conflict
but i i wonder if right at the point
where the finger trap has been ripped to
shreds and there's no you know coming
back i mean one of the things i you know
when people were really fighting in 2020
i was like well let's do tulsi gabbard
like she would be like the compromise
candidate for both parties and what on
both sides and what happened with the
left
yeah the
when i suggested this my uh some of my
friends
on facebook went ape [ __ ] saying she was
just a uh
an evil republican yes this is why i say
like
you know when you say the left has the
same thing about us i'm like yes but
we're right it's very simple because i'm
not a traditional conservative i've
never been a conservative and i
supported yang and tulsi in 2020 trying
to find that compromise that the
establishment left and the leftists were
unwilling to have so some of my friends
were receptive to it too too though so i
mean yeah just keep trying but i think i
think those for sure for sure i think a
lot of people who watch this show even
were probably like oh yeah i used to
vote democrat then we started paying
attention and now we're just like i'm
not interested i'm not saying
republicans are going to solve your
problems i don't think they are i think
they're going to do a lot of nothing i
like your metaphor about the shields
creating more than the finger trap
because it's like if you're angry about
what you're communicating because you've
been upset by what they did then people
can tell and they don't want to listen
but if you're if you don't have that
resistance and you're just stating it
yeah biden you know he bribed those guys
to to fire that prosecutor so that he
prisma didn't get investigated that's
pretty much that's that's a fact i saw
on tv
i should say i'm not mad about it it
happened
why did biden do it well we can say it
it's corruption either way because
telling a foreign country that you will
withhold aid to them unless they fire
someone that's a corrupt act he doesn't
have the authority to do that and they
even told him that he bragged about it
and said call the president see what he
says like wow he's bragging about
superseding the will of the people
that's crazy now did he do it to protect
his son
that's a question needs to be an answer
to an investigation what do we know
the prosecutor was investigating barisma
his son was on the board joe biden did
intervene you don't talk about motives
or incentives i don't care he did it
so
now you investigate look into emails
determine whether or not he did it to
protect a son or not but either way like
he bragged about doing it now when we
say that
who's telling the truth i mean that's a
conversation i had with my dad a couple
a few days ago about the facts because
he was like when he watches this show
from time to time he's like oh you there
you guys are saying wrong the wrong
information is what you're saying is
wrong and i'm like well what's right
what's true there's so much information
being shoved into and he was actually
like but i mean what's true how do you
know what's true you get 80 million
different pieces of information from 80
million different sources and and
they're all
they're all
like they might be right they might be
wrong so it's like we get we get things
wrong yeah
the things we get wrong aren't like core
details on major political events the
things we get wrong are like i'll i'll
say a caliber of a gun and then someone
will chat be like tim you're wrong about
that it's actually this i'm like oh that
was a mistake yeah but to them you're in
the same category as q anon people who
believe all sorts of crazy stuff right
and we're not right but that's not what
they that's not how they see it but they
are
the the the blue and on people and q and
on people they they they would get along
swimmingly in their weird beliefs and
things that aren't true yeah you tend to
see in others what's in you
but look q anon is fringe
mainstream conservatives and
libertarians aren't entertaining q anon
people
blue anon is mainstream democrat they
believe for years the ukraine gate
russia gate stuff that's all been
debunked
yeah i mean i know i agree like
you know i would say
in silicon valley the republicans
justifiably lost like any support for
the future with like cheney and bush
and i would say the same thing today
that like the democrats have equally
deserved like no support in the future
from any of these if anybody who's
principled i would say quit what
concerns quit your quit your party if
you're democrat but if you if you go to
your average republican and ask them
about some crazy conspiracy
they might give you a half-baked answer
where it's like well i don't know but
you know these things i think are weird
and i read this somewhere if you go to
your mainstream democrat and ask them
about like russia and stuff they're
probably going to be like yeah i think
he did it
sure and it's like even though mueller
proved it wasn't true even though now
with the sussman trial we're learning
about hillary clinton's role in signing
off on these things they're going to be
like i don't know about that i mean
first of all i'm still manning my
friends just here just so you know but
um you know they would say
well
yeah we know that the there we know that
there was all this stuff that's like
shady about the the report um that came
came out of england or whatever but we
still know that there's like
collusion happening between trump and
trump and russia like we know that he
has hotel deals he wants in moscow and
and they'll say stuff like that and you
know to some degree you know
there's probably you know there's
you know you can't be as successful as
donald trump was without you know having
to bend the law a little bit i think
for sure you know and so we we we talk
about uh trump and the things we
actually don't like about his presidency
relatively often drone strikes and you
know why that happened things like that
um donald trump whether it was him or or
someone else trump hotels were being
advertised on a state department website
like these are bad things trump tried to
have i think the g7 at trump doral in
florida like really bad thing you
shouldn't do it and trump was like but
i'm gonna do it at cost and i said so
what you're still maintaining your
business through a government contract i
think that's wrong i got no problem
saying that but then you hear from a lot
of these people
they won't even bother watching a show
like this i mean let alone google
searching half the news that comes out
that to me
i'm sorry if i'm a little pessimistic in
that regard but i think you know we talk
about technology and all these things
and i don't think that's the issue i do
think
we need technology to be developed
because there may come a time when we
get cut off completely from silicon
valley
if a civil war really is coming
or we're in one fourth fifth
generational warfare whatever it may be
what do you think is going to happen to
the anti-establishment
when
states start breaking apart
san francisco is going to be like
eliminate all the ips from states that
we don't like and then how will you
communicate what will you be using
there's going to need to be something
so that that in that sense technology
that's why i you know i like rumble
cloud service because i'm like
they might censor me so what you said
earlier aaron was interesting that
silicon valley people there got
disenfranchised with the republicans
with bush and cheney and then now
they're being disenfranchised with this
ridiculousness in the democrats side i
hope so i may not be my hope i'm not
there anymore so but what the problem
with that is that who who they care
about now while they care about the
corporation so who's the new authority
the corporation i mean if google thinks
it's running the show now because the
court the politicians are incompetent
that's kind of like maybe even worse i
don't know what's worse an incompetent
president or a corporation that thinks
it's in charge
i don't know that's a good question um i
would hope that they're still
anti-corporation too i mean the left was
supposed to always be anti-corporation
like from
by for my entire life and so yeah it's
uh it's another pro corporate i can't
even stop at google it's alphabet which
is owned by blackrock i mean it's not
it's it's in part
owned by blackrock state street vanguard
yeah and that is that is purely a result
of the propaganda to like try to scare
people about like you know the
corporations are only hope against these
evil racists in kentucky or whatever who
you know are gonna you know would be
throwing gay people off of buildings if
they had their way um
so
yeah well now there's a big scandal in
the uk because they
they were flying the union jack over
some street
and all these leftists are like this is
what the nazis did and it's like yo it's
your country's flag
like just because the nazis drank water
doesn't mean you shouldn't drink water
you know i'm thinking about posobic i
don't know if you guys heard jack
posobik he was in uh it went to davos a
couple days ago and was detained by by
klaus schwab's personal guard i don't
know if they were they're private
players i believe yeah were they private
police no swiss police it looks like
they were just i was told they were
private i could be wrong okay maybe they
were they were wearing police on their
yeah so maybe it was maybe it was police
maybe it was corporate security i don't
know they were wearing police on their
uniforms yeah
so maybe it was swiss police let's just
stop there then i don't know for sure if
it was if it was a private guard but uh
you know you see this corporate private
guard
and they don't care about the law they
care about serving the corporation where
they get paid
that's uh that's where we're i think
that's the fear i'm not so worried about
the politics i'm worried about these
corporations that are sneaking and
trying to buy up land
bill gates
what is the single largest owner of
farmland that doesn't mean he owns all
of the farmland it means for a single
entity he owns more than anybody else
that's a lot
it's a weird i don't trust that guy yeah
i don't want to pile on the guy but man
he is he is and where's luke at he's
coming we need him to hear you luke
is luke in the chat i don't know
probably hi luke if you're watching luke
rutkowski ladies and gentlemen we are
change big fan
yeah i mean it's it's funny how you have
uh
you have this belief
or i don't know how you describe it but
um
you have multinational corporations
politicians they meet together in big
international conferences the new york
times are invited guests of at the world
economic forum along with world leaders
and people like bill gates where they're
talking about really horrifying things
like
what do they say implantable biotracking
or whatever
for your lives tracking your carbon
footprint yeah for for better compliance
yep
they talk about like mandating health
requirement stuff it's so crazy because
it's not american i for a while it was
like i just disbelieve it i couldn't
even begin to believe that people
thought that way because i'm like no i'm
born in america first amendments is
paramount you don't do that to people
that doesn't happen but now i'm really
they're not from america they're not
from the united they don't think like
that this is like authoritarian weird
european pseudo-communist fascist nazi
stuff
freaking and technocratic yeah there are
misconceptions sorry good
there are misconceptions about just how
popular like the um i i hate the term
free speech absolutism because it kind
of begs the question but the american
first amendment conception of free
speech is not unique in the world but
it's very rare uh and and i think
one of my worries is that i think it's
actually becoming increasingly rare just
in a gut conception of what free speech
is in the younger generation and
millennials now gen z is even more so
um and to address what you're saying is
the government the worst is the
corporation's the worst
i i would split the difference and say
the worst possible state of affairs uh
is one where they're both
both the government and corporations are
competing to please each other that you
have in place uh a corporate apparatus
that can
do things that a state would like it to
do
without repercussions so i want to
people are saying that the police
actually were wearing badges that said
world economic forum police on their
arms
so that's actually what jack he said to
their world economic forum police so
that's a private company and it's they
have the word police on it which is
interesting because i used to think of
police as a public service but not in
switzerland apparently i would i mean
it's not surprising in switzerland no
it's not but i better doubt man
that was a big blizzard it was crazy
every everybody was there was like
betting on crypto for the future all
these ultra rich people yeah you guys
got deep in crypto
uh not really no um
i mean crypto is something we've been
looking at a lot
recently
it's actually
it's been overhyped and we're kind of
disappointed that
we wanted to find a lot of
anti-establishment engineers to kind of
just make these kind of decentralized
things and open source things that you
know
help free us from the oligopoly and
unfortunately a lot of the attention
you know i i like to say you know all
the elite engineers are either working
for google
but those who aren't are working for uh
trying to do cryptocurrency schemes um
and
some of them are you know bitcoin works
you know it's great a lot of these
things are just complete nonsense
they don't work they're not going to
work
i remember in the early days scheme some
of them yeah i remember in the early
days
there were just hundreds of coins that
were derivative of bitcoin
and people were just trading between
them and it was nonsense
it was like they were all basically just
slight alterations of bitcoin for some
reason people bought the craziest thing
was when there would be a coin
that was the lowest possible value it
could be
like
an you know eighth decimal point of a
cent
so if you bought a ton of it it could
only double so people would do it so
people would put like a thousand bucks
into the most worthless thing possible
because the very least you sold it and
got your money back because it couldn't
go any lower
it's the weirdest thing and then if it
went up to two you doubled your money
and you pulled out
crazy back in the day with crypto it was
just weird stuff game of hot potato
ponzi schemes whatever yeah you need
utility i like the mines coin as an
example because you use one coin on the
mines network to get a thousand views of
advertising
bill's been really good about making
sure minds is like not not like
what i was talking about like it's
you know
not treated more seriously than it
should be and it's kind of useful they
didn't take a pre-sale like the ceo
didn't take 20 of the coins before they
went live they just all went live he
buys them just like everyone else he has
to get them just like everyone else does
that's a legitimate thing and then they
won't nail it as a securities fraud it's
not a ponzi scheme it actually has value
on the network but then do you need
crypto
well you gotta you got to be able to
defend yourself against the swift
payment system if they want to cut off
your bank account i don't know if you
need crypto necessarily but couldn't you
just make like
the mines coin you know facebook did
this before remember when they tried
making their own currency
yeah i mean they did try and telegram
did too no no even before libra i'm
pretty sure they'd like facebook coin or
something oh yeah before crypto
they were like tokens you could get for
like the games or whatever i mean yeah
that's just that's not even a blockchain
that's just right no it's like it's like
an in-app purchase in a video game like
yeah and it's like having gems and zelda
you know but you can use them on
facebook
yeah
i understand the diablo uh diablo 2 gold
was actually like a usable currency in
some countries for a while
oh yeah world of warcraft gold also
that actually had value because they
were you know people wanted it so they
were farming and selling it but now
world of warcraft allows you to just buy
you know buy gold you buy a token that
gives someone a month of gameplay and
then they spend 20 000 gold on it so
then the economy is totally manipulated
you know i just want to say this guys
if uh if you like
if you're not a fan of communism
if you want to explain inflation to
somebody just in introduce them to world
of warcraft or if you know any
socialists who play just ask them have
they ever noticed why it makes no sense
that linen costs like
30 gold
so let me let me simplify this for you
guys
you don't need to be a fan of video
games or anything like that for to
understand what's important or how it's
a good you know reference for people
in the early days of world of warcraft
there's a game mechanic secondary class
uh
i'll call professions so um when you go
out and you're fighting bandits and then
they die you take their clothes you get
linen cloth you can then use that cloth
to make armor or you can do leather
working you you kill a boar and then you
skin it take its leather
it used to be worthless
because the the value of the item you
got was comparable to the level you were
if you just started the game and it's
easy to kill these things it's not very
valuable now is it but then they rolled
out the mass printing of currency by
allowing you to buy money so if you
start the game you can be like i want to
buy the best item so i'm going to give
hard u.s cash to just have all the gold
i want without doing any work for it
well what ends up happening is now the
lowest level items cost obscene amounts
of money if you start the game off
you'll have no way of making that money
i guess you it's hyperinflation you get
the land and then you sell it for a
bunch of money and then the economy
makes literally no sense anymore
that's what the mass printing of money
does makes everything cost more and
world of warcraft is the easiest way to
make these young gen z or millennial
socialists understand it thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there